we're not talking honestly about what it
really takes to get from poverty to the
middle class so for example we know that
only 4% of people who are born into
poverty will ever make it to the
upper-middle class or to you know have
middle-class success and so what that
means is that 96% of people are not
making it out and I think we're being
dishonest when we say everybody has a
fair and equal chance of achieving the
American dream so it wasn't until
college that I figured out that I was
poor I hadn't before then I had no
context for what it meant to have less
than other people who lived around me or
crosstown and I certainly didn't know
that I was outside of what was
considered the middle class and the
first time that I heard about people
living in poverty was in a political
science class and there we were talking
about on welfare policies and one of the
big policies at the time was welfare
reform and the debate was raging about
what should be done and a lot of the
conversation was up here and really
detached from the women and families
that were going to be directly impacted
by the policy so we heard a lot of
things about welfare queens people
living off the system not wanting to
work women being lazy having multiple
children and that really wasn't the
reality for the women who were actually
impoverished and so when we look at the
kind of policies that result are the tan
of policy the welfare reform policy that
we got on the other end we got a policy
that said well you can't if you don't
work you can't receive benefits and you
have time limits and if you have another
child you're penalized those policies
and those that restrictiveness was
counter to the everyday lived
experiences of the women who were
actually receiving the benefits so what
was excluded from that policy was a
clear pathway out of poverty like
education were there missing in the very
beginning there was very few provisions
for child care and a lot of other things
that we know family and women need
need to be able to chart a path out of
poverty when people think of poverty
they think about money and resources and
cash but a big part of poverty is the
lack of social connections and social
networks and what we know is that those
social networks and connections are
really powerful in terms of helping
people to navigate complex institutions
and structures and for for for poor
people those social networks are often
missing and when we talk about bridging
from the from poverty to the middle
class social networks and social capital
that are really important to making that
that leap and so when we talk about what
can institutions and leaders do to
support that it's really important to
make sure that children and people in
low-income neighborhoods have have Apple
access to bridge opportunities that meet
meaning opportunities outside of their
community
that they're engaged in programs not
only within their community but outside
of the community that that connect them
to people outside of their normal social
network what we need to do is be working
together across class across race and
across all these markers of difference
to figure out what are the connections
how might we support one another and
looking at the richness of what each of
us bring to the table as opposed to
assuming there's a deficit model come a
deficit coming from one end the poor
housing the poor quality schools the
infrastructure the lack of libraries and
institutions and communities and
hospitals and high unemployment we're
not talking about how those things are
barriers in and of themselves to people
escaping poverty and so when those
things are absent from communities
people are rightly preoccupied with
securing those things and we're not
having that conversation about what does
it really look like for a community to
be thriving we know what it looks like
we've seen it you know we know that
communities that have great schools low
low levels of unemployment low levels of
crime high civic engagement
great grocery stores and banks those
communities are doing well the people
and the kids in those communities are
doing well and when those things are
absent
we know that the communities are not
working and that people are struggling
and so we just need to be honest about
what it really takes for everybody to
have a fair shot at the American dream